j - avant l'ouverture du nouveau cinéma
du centre commercial vélizy 2 les
derniers travaux se terminent pour
accueillir dans les meilleures
conditions le public
au total le multiplex comprend 18 salles
pour en recevoir 3800 spectateurs alors
les salles sont pour moi tout de la même
qualité ça c'est les références
aujourd'hui tant qu'elles soient petites
ou grandes c'est les mamans on va de 95
places à 475 avec des écrans de 10 à 18
m elles sont toutes équipées de la
dernière tlg technologie d'imagés sont
pour un confort et une projection de
qualité maximum pour nos spectateurs au
niveau de la programmation le cinéma
proposera une large sélection sur ses
écrans pour attirer plus de six cent
mille spectateurs tous les ans on va
évidemment du blockbuster prêt familial
ça va être demain captain marvel mais
également qu'est ce qu'on a fait au bon
dieu des choses comme ça au film
d'auteur 18 salles c'est vraiment la
diversité qu'on offre donc voilà du film
très populaire au film très d'auteur en
passant par des ugc culte donc la
reprise de deux films qui ont marqué
l'histoire du cinéma
et j'ai également des documentaires des
films pour enfants débiles héritage des
choses comme ça le cinéma de 15 mille
cinq cents mètres carrés veut également
assuré le spectacle en dehors de ces
salles obscures
pour cela le sida décidé de laisser
entrer l'art contemporain dans ses murs
les spectateurs pourront notamment voir
ses yeux de chat géant de l'artiste
claude lévêque travail sur le thème du
regard zappé le cinéma sont des regards
sont des yeux il a pensé simone signoret
dans le film le chat et du coup fait il
ya eu ce travail en lettres le cinéma
ouvrira officiellement ses portes ce
mercredi 6 mars les premières séances
sont programmées à partir de 10 heures